why is the stock market in the United
States up yeah but there's this thing
called the S P 500 we all know what that
is you've got the Dow Jones Industrial
Average you get the S P 500 and you got
the NASDAQ 100. I have a chart that I
want to show you because in the middle
of all this uh you're hearing about 14
consecutive times a government
announcements that they beaten the
guidance on unemployment yeah that's
because they keep making announcements
and then adjusting it down behind our
backs you can Google this you can go
search for this it is so true the US
government is manipulating labor stats
to make it look like they're beating 14
in a row Home Market you got all these
interest rates mortgages what's going on
with all that it seems down you know
layoffs are certainly down if you're the
one being laid off and then we got the
stock market up what's going on 85 of
the pump that has happened in the S P
500 since January look at this is seven
stocks Microsoft Facebook Amazon Nvidia
Google Apple Tesla